the cdc defines heavy drinking as 15 or
more drinks a week for men and eight or
more drinks per week for women
selena gomez has something to say to the
haters commenting on her latest tic tac
on tuesday the only murders in the
building star posted a reaction clip to
a video of dr dawn bantal explaining the
definition of heavy drinking
the cdc defines heavy drinking as 15 or
more drinks a week for men and eight or
more drinks per week for women
that's the come and get it singer
playfully looking nervous as she listens
to the facts and just in case there was
any doubt cell captioned the post quote
it's a joke i think it is important to
kind of go through your life the way you
want well some followers didn't get the
memo and in a now deleted comment one
tick tock user wrote quote so one of
your best friends gives you her kidney
and you continue to drink excessively
damn selena selena's response quote it
was a joke ass
i don't want people to think it's a sad
thing that i went through this with
francio or with anything in my life
because at the end of the day i think
all the stuff that i went through
made me and defined everything that i am
right now of course the former disney
star revealed she had been diagnosed
with lupus back in 2015 adding that
she's been through chemotherapy and in
2017 as a result of lupus complications
she underwent a kidney transplant her
donor close friend and grownish star
francia raisa who opened up to e.t about
the whole experience in 2020 i just
recently started talking about being a
living kidney donor i started talking
about it on valentine's day because it's
also national organ donor day and i've
received such positive feedback from
people and i didn't realize for myself
how important it was to speak to other
donors that knew exactly what i was
going through so it was also rewarding
for me as much as it was for them to
like kind of form that little
community last year selena's transplant
was used as a joke in the save by the
bell reboot during a scene when two
characters are seen arguing over who
donated selena's kidney now i know for a
fact that selena gomez's kidney donor
was justin bieber's mom it was demi
lovato's kidney and a source at the time
told et that selena wasn't amused by all
that
selena was really upset by the save by
the bell scene about her health and
thought of it as bullying and offensive
she felt as though her kidney transplant
and others who have gone through that
was used as a joke at her expense
and you know who else was upset selena's
loyal fans after they expressed their
outrage online and hashtag respect
selena gomez started trending on twitter
saved by the bell's streaming network
peacock its parent company nbc universal
and the show's executive producers all
issued an apology quote we apologize it
was never our intention to make light of
selena's health we have been in touch
with our team and will be making a
donation to her charity the selena gomez
fund for lupus research at usc
brancia also reacted to the controversy
on her insta story writing that some of
the cast and producers reached out to
her personally to apologize adding quote
i truly appreciate that
[Music]
you